do you know what the most iconic formula
in microsoft excel
for aspiring consultants is this formula
or more precisely combination of
formulas is so well known
so ubiquitous in consulting that there
are tons of memes on all the consulting
meme channels out there
just about this formula in excel and
this
formula or combination of formulas is of
course
index match index match is a formula in
excel which is
often used by more competent more senior
consultants to divide the cohort of
consultants into the beginners
and those that are a bit more advanced
specifically when it comes to excel
index match is considered a bit of a
more advanced formula combination in
excel
and many new joiners in consulting do
not
really know how to use it so this is
true for you as well
do not worry no more i will show you how
index match works i will show you in
detail how the formula is working
and then also put together a simple
little excel exercise
based on a financial modeling situation
and show you how you could resolve it
with index match
welcome to another coffee break with me
here on my channel firm learning this
is the place where i want to help you to
be successful
in the first years of your career as
always if you took any value out of this
video at all please hit the like button
for the youtube algorithm and also
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date
i release at least one video every week
on
saturdays but let's not jump into it
what is index
match and why is it so important for
consultants so as a small motivation
let's just
check out these hilarious index match
memes and if i just type in index match
meme in google then here in the picture
search you can already see a whole lot
of
memes just around this topic of index
match i just pre-opened here a couple of
them let's go over them
so here vlookup no and index match yes
this is what you want to go for
and indeed index matches often
contrasted with vlookup
and then vlookup is often then
considered the beginner you know the
noob version of the formula whereas the
real pros
are using index match a bit similar to
that is this one here
so vlookup no thank you but index match
is
what you need to do then next one
actually user index match vlookup again
the rivalry between next match and
vlookup of course index match is what is
considered superior here
and yes then the consultants who are
able of doing index match sometimes
consider themselves of super
professional actual users
and then finally here just a comparison
of vlookup and index match
so vlookup is super popular whereas
index matches not so much and
probably the main reason why vlookup is
so popular is because it's much easier
to use
but actually index match is much more
powerful it's much more flexible in the
way how you can use it and it's also
much more error prone in many ways and
also it is faster
so excel takes less time to calculate it
and probably this was something that was
even more relevant in the past and not
so much with the newer versions of excel
but still index match is considered a
more and better performing version of
the lookup but now enough with these
jokes let's now understand how you can
use index match let's learn how it
really works and i will contrast it with
vlookup
just to make sure that you understand
the differences and the business setting
the business application
that i want to have here is a little
small exercise and this is something
that you could
easily then also be exposed to in any
financial modeling type of situation
now here we are facing the situation
that we are a retail company
we have a number of stores so now i just
gave
a unique number to every store so these
are pretty much now the names of the
stores
and now each of these stores had a
forecast for the year
so for the next year there's a company
plan
and now these are the values that these
stores are supposed to make
but now you want to break down these
yearly targets
to the individual monthly values okay
and you want to do that by pretty much
applying the historic distribution of
the revenues across the months
and let's not just assume that one
somebody from the finance department
put together for each of these stores
you know you can see that they are
orders these are now the exact 30 stores
that we saw before
here we put together what the percentage
of the revenues
are that accrue in the individual months
based on historic figures so how this
distribution was in the prior years
and here you always see that the total
for each line is 100 so this is always
the sum of these values
but you can see that the distribution is
quite different so for instance store
number one made eighteen point eight
percent of the revenues in january
whereas store number two made seven
percent of the revenues in january
and now we need to do the following
namely we need to
multiply this number with the
corresponding
percentage of the historic split
and this is something where you would
usually use
a lookup for and so what you need here
is a two-dimensional lookup
true pretty much picking the right value
for the store
and for the month so two dimensional
lookup so let's now start by looking
into how this would work with vlookup
and now i will assume that you have an
understanding of how vlookup works if
you don't then please just
look it up there are many resources on
that online i will later explain
index match in much more detail but
vlookup just as a basic comparison
and what most people will do i can tell
you from my experience if
they would need to do something like
this they will type in vlookup
they choose here the lookup value
then here you fix now of course the
columns
then you need to choose then the table
array
so this is always the first table where
the reference the id number is
and then here they choose the columns
that are relevant here the 13 columns
and now for january they then put the
number two because this is then the
second
column and then an exact match and then
what you have here
this is now a percentage value right but
what you have here is 0.09
which should be the value from january
for store number six
so let's check store number six january
is 8.7
so i assume if you just take one more
digits here 8.7 this is now the
percentage figure that we got earlier
but now of course the downside is even
if i now fix this reference here if i
want to now have it for february for the
next month if i just copy it over
it doesn't work because this 2 this
number is not dynamic
but here for february i would need a 3
right so the next column in the
historical split table
to really make use of that so actually
what i have seen people do is that then
they would actually just
manually type in here a three
and here a four and so on just to get
all the monthly values correct so let's
just
check here four six eight seven thirteen
point two so this fits
and then here twelve point seven so this
fits as well
but of course not typing all of this in
manually of course
isn't really the way to go and of course
now maybe for the 12 fields here it
might even work but now imagine having
to do this for a much
larger table which many more columns
then you just wouldn't be able to handle
and then what some maybe a bit smarter
people would do is that they would
include something like a helper line
here where then instead of writing the
two out
they will just link it here and then
basically do it like this and now of
course you have the advantage of being
able to automate it in some ways
but now what do you do if for whatever
reason here
a new column gets inserted because now
this doesn't work anymore because now
the fifth
column here is empty whereas you want to
have the value for
april in that column here for april
right and so for all these
kinds of reasons using vlookup in the
classical setup
just doesn't make a lot of sense and is
just not recommended and just not really
considered professional
and this is now really where index match
comes into play so how does index match
work before we now dive into the numbers
here let me try to give you a bit more
of an intuitive
explanation into all of this so index
match is a combination of two formulas
it's a combination of the
index formula which is then combined
with the match formula
so how do these two formulas work
together and how it works is that
in the index formula you define an array
so basically you define
a range of a table so certain reference
which can be somewhere in the middle of
an excel sheet
that is now the new range where the
formula looks into
and now so applying this to this
historical split table that we used
here we had all the numbers of the
stores so from one to five until
the very end you had 30 and then on this
axis you had january
february march april and so on
and now what the match formula does
is it looks both into the rows and
also into the columns and saying okay
return to me
what number here is for instance the
store number three
and now because this is ordered the
store number three
also comes into the third position in
this array
and the same is not true for the second
match formula that we will use to now
pull
up the columns and here again now for
instance it could look into okay what
number
in this array is actually the
month of april and here now the way we
have set it up here
it would be one two three four right
and then it can give me pretty much the
number
three in the rows and the number four
in the columns so then put up this exact
value
so this is how i use it and i can
understand if now this is
was a bit hard to follow but let's now
jump into the practical
example to really bring this to life and
we now start by
setting up the index formula and here
now this is now the index for the store
number six
but first we need to define the array so
the overall table that now the values
are supposed to be pulled out
and here we now just mark this data
table here so now i just made a
reference here from a3 to n33 just to
mark this whole
table here and i fix it so now we have
the whole array defined so this is now
the overall field from which x and now
will pull out the individual numbers
and now it asks for a row number and for
a column number so how this works is
that now the very first
field of this array and here you see it
starts at the field a3
this now has the row number one and the
column number one so this is field one
one this one here one below this would
be the
row number two because there are two
rows and then still the column one
this field here for instance this would
be the row number
one two three and then the column number
one two three four so three four would
give us in this field
so let's now just do an example for this
store six january that we just had
selected and now for
january this would be the number that we
would want to pull up right so the eight
point
seven percent and this now would pretty
much mean
a row number of seven so this is the
seventh
row right so one two three four five
six seven so for the row number these
are he is asking you for we type in a
seven
and then for the column number because
this is january this is the second
column so we type in here the second
column
and now this is already what we have
and if we now type this in then of
course we get exactly this number eight
point seven percent
and this was this number here that we
wanted
so far so good but now of course you
want to make this dynamic
because now you would have the same
problem as if you would just use
the the vlookup in the prior example and
what you want to use here instead
are now the match formulas so both of
these two numbers
both the column and the row lookup needs
to be replaced by a match formula
and let's just start here by the row
number so we
pull up the match formula and now he
looks for a lookup value
and in the rows you remember that we had
the stores so we now
highlight here the store value we fix
the columns to be able to now always
look up here the stores in every field
now it asks for a lookup array for the
match
and now you need to highlight the exact
column from the exact length as you also
did for the array
so you see regarding the rows that the
rows go from
3 to 33 so now here is where you need to
create
a match lookup array that has the same
kind of
size namely a3 to a33
and then the match type is zero
so let's now see if this was done
correctly because if it did it should
still now give us
the 8.7 and it does right it still gives
us the 8.7
percent over here because it's formatted
as a euro value
0.087 and now let's just
check just to double triple check if
this is really the case if we evaluate
this expression
and you can always do that by pressing
f9 if you press f9 on such a thing
it returns the value that then the
certain formula within a formula is
actually returning
so if i press f9 i can see that this
whole match expression
is returning the value 7 which is
exactly the one
that we expected it to return so just to
explain it again why
is this returning a 7 because the match
formula
as we had here it now gives a certain
range as we now have defined it here
from a 3 to a 33 this is how we set it
up so from here to here this is what we
gave as a lookup value
and now it takes this value here this we
hear defined the value six
it now goes into this range and it
looks for this value six right so it
looks in this range where
is the value six and now of course it
finds it here
and now it returns the relative position
of this element in this lookup area
so now starting at the top it counts one
two three
four five six seven so it says okay this
value that i found here this value six
is the seventh number the seventh item
in this lookup area and this of course
now is exactly what we wanted to do
right because we want to know
what number it is regarding the rows and
this is exactly what the match formula
is returning
and as we already know this is now seven
which is right it returns a seven so now
let's do the same thing
for the columns and again we use instead
of not manually writing it in match
for for returning the column figure
and we do that again first by providing
the lookup value
and now in the columns it's the months
right so you want to
look up the months in the new lookup
area so here you know
highlight or select this january
thing and now you fix the row
and now next you define the lookup area
or the lookup array
and this is now here this one and again
you need to go
over the same size exactly how your
overall index area was set up
and you see that this was going from
column a
to column n so here you know to me to
make sure that this is now going from
column a
to column n to really make these
arrays a match right so that now the
first
second third fourth etc position of this
array is the same as the number of
regarding the positions of the columns
of the overall array that you defined
here from the index
so let's now fix that as well and let's
now
again do the match type and this is
supposed to be
always a zero an exact match and now
again it stays at the same number so
this seems to be correct and if we now
evaluate this
second match formula it returns a two
and this of course is exactly what we
wanted to do so again how does this work
here we gave the january as the lookup
value
then here we defined the array and now
it looks into this area into this array
what position starting here from the
left is
this value that he's looking for namely
this gen the general
value and now here you can actually see
that it's the second one
from the left so it returns the number
or the index two
and now with these two lookup values
pretty much the
row index and the column index we can
then really look up
exactly this precise percentage that we
were looking for here
and now of course the beauty is if we
fixed all of this correctly and already
see that here now we haven't
fixed this properly so let's just check
this is fully fixed here the
column is fixed this is fixed here the
rows are fixed and this is fixed so it
should be fine
if we now copy it over
so it should be now able to directly
give the correct numbers here
everywhere and this already looks quite
good so let's just
check by including the
sum values because now every row should
return
the number one so i just included here
the sums for every row
because of course these were percentage
figures and
now the sum of all these percentages
should add up to 100
to super number one so let's just pick
up the row 22 as a
check and here the store 22 you see it
starts with
1.0 this is exactly what you have here 1
or 14.2 this is what you have here then
the last one is
6.9 so yes it did seem to give us the
correct values here
so now you directly filled all the
percentages with this index match
technique
and of course the last thing that you
want to do is that you want to multiply
this whole thing
with the revenue the total yearly
revenue target
in order to now get the actual targets
that you have
and now you do that by multiplying it
and
fixing the columns and if you do that
you can kind of pretty much directly see
that now some numbers come up that look
good so now just to make these better
readable
let's just work with these little things
here
and now what you can already see is that
now here the total
adds up to exact same number as this
total here which is of course correct
this is exactly how it's supposed to be
so let's just triple check by adding a
sum here
and then also adding the same sum
function over
this range here and now yes you can see
that
it adds up to the very same number as
it should so this is how it works this
is how you use index
match and just going back to the example
that we had earlier
if we now here start adding
a new column for instance so even
several new columns
all of this should not be bothered at
all because because we made this as a
reference now again it includes
automatically all the ranges
so you can see that instead of going
from a to n as before
now it just goes from from a to p so
just expanded that
and because it doesn't care about the
absolute value here
you just with the match you just
directly pull up the right index
and of course you could have also
included the match
function in your vlookup to do that
instead but then if you start doing that
then why not directly using index match
and get the other benefits like the
performance improvements this way so i
hope that this was helpful
so the bottom line is that pretty much
whenever you want to use a
two-dimensional lookup
in most cases using an index match is
the way to go
and even with only a one-dimensional
lookup there can be reasons where then
you would choose an
index match over just the vlookup of
course there are good reasons to look
vlookup as well probably
just easier to set up just a bit more
convenient
and probably even the the biggest pros
you know still using vlookup
if they just quickly want to do
something even though maybe they just
claim or pretend they don't but i mean
it's okay right but just be aware when
you use it and be aware of the
disadvantages
and all that this really helps you know
to step up your exit skills because
index match is something that requires a
bit
more of an advanced understanding but
once you got it once you understand it
then it's still pretty quick and pretty
easy to set up
and so i hope that i was able to teach
you the basics that you have now this
basic understanding
and can now incorporate index match into
your excel toolkit this way so i hope
you found this helpful and this really
helped you to use and apply index match
for your own excel models as
always if you have any questions please
leave a comment below in the comment
section i will do my very best to answer
every single one if you took
any value out of this video please
destroy the like button for the youtube
algorithm and also subscribe
and also turn the notifications on with
the bell icon
to make sure that you really see every
single video of myself if you want to
see even more content like that you can
also follow me on my instagram my handle
is firm learning
and also do not forget to sign up for my
email list you can find a link
to the sign up form in my video
description thank you guys for watching
i really appreciate your time and i hope
you got some value out of this video
the next video will be released next
saturday so stay tuned for that and
until then
keep learning and have a good weekend